así lucía xiomara castró el 28 de
noviembre de 2021 celebraba su victoria
electoral después de años intentando
devolver a la izquierda a la presidencia
con 60 diputados entre su partido libre
y alianzas quedó a tan solo 5 de la
mayoría parecía que podría lograr
legislar con pactos
mucho más difícil se volvió la
gobernabilidad este viernes 21 de enero
especialmente tras los golpes entre
diputados de su propio partido
en campaña xiomara había logrado un
pacto con salvador nasralá éste
establecía que el partido salvador de
honduras escogería la presidencia del
congreso 20 diputados en rebeldía de
libres se opusieron al pacto por lo que
este domingo escogieron a jorge cálix de
este partido como presidente del
congreso lo hicieron con el apoyo del
derechista partido nacional del
presidente juan orlando hernández al que
investigan por vínculos con el
narcotráfico esta votación se produjo en
un club social a las afueras de
tegucigalpa en el congreso- xiomara
castró siguió con su plan y los
diputados presentes se escogieron como
presidente del congreso a luís redondo
del partido de salvador nasralá la
votación se produjo con seguidores de
xiomara en las calles honduras tiene
ahora los congresos y la jura
presidencial serán jueves tomará anunció
que ésta se realizará ante un juez civil
mientras los analistas concluyen que la
rebeldía de sus diputados a los que
acusó de traidores son los últimos
golpes del presidente saliente juan
orlando hernández aprovechando las
ambiciones personales y políticas de los
díscolos y dejan así una honduras que se
presume ingobernable